what's up guys welcome Finity we have  trusted 400,000 subscribers thank you so  much for all their support so I think  it's some CML in action once that match  me against them let's go good luck  All Right game on zero zero  [Music]  that was a pretty perfect light return I  wasn't expecting the shorter yeah  [Music]  [Applause]  ah I went for feedback on  [Music]  why does a good strawberry  [Music]  how did I miss that  [Music]  got me  [Music]  [Music]  my reaction time was by two seconds  slower that mean  [Applause]  I had my chance there  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  I'll set you up  Oh  [Music]  no don't get me with the edge yeah sexy  it's not even dead  [Music]  come on lucky lucky one  [Music]  the words that we heard bye guys much  voila  alright well that was decent though it  was but stay tuned for the big 500k  match against me and hasta the stakes  are high  check subscribe here and watch our  previous subscribe there I feel next  time